- [Speaker] All right.
Looks like a crowd.
Wow.
Yeah.
Nice.
Love the energy from the three people
that are probably done with their day
and have to deal
with one more person talking about AI.
Of course.
All right.
So I'll try to make it
fun for the three people
that are looking at me.
I will not be the first
person you've heard this from.
I will most definitely
not be the last person
you've heard this from.
But 2025 was the year of agents,
and I would say probably the next decade
will be the year of agents.
So at Fireworks AI, we've helped a ton
of companies, right across all different
use cases to build agents in production.
That includes coding agents with a lot
of the companies when
you walk around here,
they're using us, document agents
that process banking information,
legal information, all of
these different things,
sales and marketing agents
that are doing outbound,
that are doing inbound, hiring agents
that are doing recruiting automatically,
customer service agents
that are increasing csat,
reducing average handling time,
you name it, right?
Across all of the industries
that you can imagine, retail, insurance,
finance, education, life science,
security, et cetera, right?
And you're saying, "Okay,
well everybody's saying
they build agents."
But the reality is a
lot of people don't talk
about how hard it is
to build agents, right?
So it sounds really sexy.
Agents are really cool.
Everybody loves talking about agents,
what people don't really talk about is
how difficult it can be to build agents
for specific business use cases, right?
So you have all of these possible errors
that can happen.
All of these possible failure modes
that can happen across multiple layers
of the stack, right?
So just starting here, like one is,
are you gonna use a closed-source model
or an open-source model?
If you're using an open-source model,
are you using a small model, maybe a 8B,
a 5B model, or are you using a large model
like Kimi or DeepSeek
that are in the trillion
of parameters, right?
Once you pick your selection
and you get your model for,
let's say it's a search use case,
what about the latency, right?
You try to deploy it, you
want your search to be
below a second, you need your LLM to be
below 300 milliseconds, right?
And putting that at scale
when you have millions of users,
that's really frigging hard, right?
And then of course,
quality is king, right?
You need to ensure that the accuracy
and the quality is the highest it can be.
Once you have all of that set out,
let's say you use the
closed-source provider,
you start to launch and
then you see, "Holy cow,
my costs are absolutely
ballooning, right?"
So you kind of got across the first three,
but now you can't really support it
because it's too expensive, right?
And then of course,
if you want to do open-source models,
then there's a lot
of infra complexity involved, right?
Are you running an EKS
cluster, ECS cluster?
How are you deploying
a across multiple nodes
with tens of GPUs, dozens of GPUs, right?
Of course there's data privacy,
compliance, security, availability.
Do you have the ML expertise?
I can go on and on, right?
And you're probably getting bored
because there's just like
so many of these errors.
Now, what I want to
convince you about today is
that at Fireworks,
we are basically the one stop shop,
the AI platform
inference and customization
engine that kind
of lets you forget about all of these
and really build what we call,
I know it's a little bit corny,
but magical AI experiences.
So what is a Fireworks platform, right?
As I said, we are an open-source inference
and customization engine
for open-source models.
At the very top layer, we make it really,
really easy for developers to use
any of the top open-source models
with day one access, right?
So that includes DeepSeek models,
actually DeepSeek
released the model today,
and it's gonna be available
on Fireworks today.
Kimi models, Llama, Minstrel, Qwen,
you name it, right?
Not only LLMs, also
vision language models,
also voice and ASR models, right?
It's incredibly easy to get started.
So we are compatible
with the OpenAI SDK Python library.
So if you're using OpenAI,
it's literally two lines of code
that you have to switch.
One is the model selection,
and then two, you just need an API key
for Fireworks, right?
Once developers basically
find the proper model
that they wanna run,
let's say they're doing
a search use case, right,
so they're running a really fast 8B
or smaller model, then what happens
very likely is that once they want
to deploy that, then they want the quality
to not only match closed-source providers,
but beat closed-source providers, right?
And they want to have
that latency of let's say,
300 milliseconds to be
stable as they scale
to millions and millions of users.
That's where our customization engine
FireOptimizer comes in, right?
So we do, and I'll talk about it in detail
in the next slide,
but we do two types of customization.
One is workload optimization.
That means if it's a search use case,
very different deployment options
than if you were
to do an agentic AI use case, right,
like some of our partners
that are around here in the area.
And then the second one is you want
to fine tune models, right?
So I have this saying that like,
generic closed-source models
are built for everyone,
but optimized for no one, right?
They're great, they're
inch deep, miles wide,
they can do a ton of different things,
but if you really push them
on a very specific use case,
they might have a lot of failure.
And I have a saying that at Fireworks,
we basically have our clients build models
with their data and then we optimize
for them, right?
As I say, like one of our co-founders
used the phrase that I like a lot,
which is, "You don't need a bazooka
to kill a mosquito," right?
And that's exactly what
Fireworks provides.
Instead of bazooka, you need something
very specific to kill that mosquito
to actually hit it, right.
That is around the fine-tuning
and the RFT reinforcement
learning fine-tuning
to really push that quality
above the closed-source providers.
And then finally, of course,
how do you scale, right?
When you're scaling to millions of users,
tens of millions of users,
you want the platform
to be super, super reliable.
You want the SLAs to be topnotch
and you want to have the highest
reliability there is.
We're able to do this
because of our phenomenal partners,
of course, of AWS as
well as Nvidia and AMD.
We have a virtual cloud infrastructure
with dozens of regions across the world
where all of the companies
basically run their open-source models on.
So that is a high level,
right, of our platform.
Now, for the few people
that are listening to me
and that are actually interested
in the nitty gritty,
I'm gonna jump into it.
So as I talked about, right,
I talked about customization
and how we customize
across two different levers, right?
One is the workload optimization.
So I don't know how many of,
there's literally five or six people,
but a show of hands who took like ML 101?
No, no one?
Okay, a couple.
You remember grid search, right,
hyperparameter tuning and
all that good stuff, right?
We computed essentially the space
that you have in order
to do a deployment across quality, speed,
and cost dimensions,
which means like spec decoder models,
the hardware that you're using,
the different execution modes,
the kernel options, et cetera.
And it's around 84,000 parameters, right?
That is a very, very large space
that no one wants to run through.
So what we've developed
is our proprietary technology,
which is called FireOptimizer,
where essentially clients work with us
and they give us their,
what we call workload profile.
So they'll tell us,
"Hey, I have a search use case.
I want the latency to be
below 200 milliseconds
and I'm gonna scale to a throughput
of let's say 200 queries
per second, right?"
From that, we basically
run it through our stack
and we identify what the optimal setup
is for them to run,
and we create a personalized
configuration deployment
with that open-source models.
Now, why we've been able to support all
of these different use cases
from the very, very low latency
to the super complex agentic AI workloads
with huge parameters is
that we've built our
stack from the ground up.
So we've optimized for every single layer
in our stack.
That starts at the lowest layer,
which is the actual CUDA kernels running
in the GPUs, right?
So we have a custom CUDA kernels
called FireAttention.
And then as you move up on the stack,
how you deploy across
multiple nodes, right,
you have to deploy, let's say a Kimi,
which is a trillion parameter model.
You need maybe 16, maybe 24 GPUs.
How you deploy that is
not trivial at all, right?
So we have disaggregated inference,
which means you're separating the prefill
from the generation, and we make it
incredibly easy for
clients to kind of forget
about all this and we'll just manage it
all for 'em, right?
And then at the very, very high level,
which is the model layer, right?
So all of these methods,
they're used across the industry,
I'd say what we do is we just
use them way better.
And that is some methods
like speculative decoding, right?
So for you that don't know
what speculative decoding is,
essentially you have a very large model,
you pair it with a very small model
that's actually generating the tokens,
and then the large model would accept
or reject the tokens, right?
If the acceptance rate is high,
then your latency can come much lower.
If the acceptance rate is low,
then it's actually counterproductive
and the latency is worse, right?
So we train our own draft
or spec decoder models in order
to push the acceptance rate way above 70%,
which makes it so that
you can get latencies
below a hundred milliseconds
for certain use cases.
So that is the workload
optimization part, right?
All about latency, cost, scalability.
The other part is really
around fine-tuning, right?
I use the maybe very
shitty but useful metaphor
of you don't need a
bazooka to kill a mosquito.
And at Fireworks, we really think that
company's moat is in owning
their own AI, right?
Like the model is their IP,
the model is their product,
and the way they do it is
by using their subject matter expertise,
their data to fine-tune models.
So we have a fine-tuning platform
that makes it really, really easy
for developers to use either
supervised fine-tuning
for, let's say intent classification,
sentiment analysis,
product catalog cleansing,
which is essentially you have images
and then you're tagging them,
whether it's gender, whether it's shoes,
whether it's the different categories,
jeans, basically the only thing
that's coming to my mind
is what I'm wearing, jackets, shirts,
et cetera, right?
So that's supervised fine-tuning.
And then we just recently released
as well reinforcement fine-tuning.
Essentially there, instead of actually
having the data set and putting the prompt
and then the response
that you want the model
for, you're writing
what is called an evaluator function
that scores the model between 0 and 1.
So the model will become
better as it learns
through its environment, right?
We've seen incredible success
with reinforcement fine-tuning
both on coding agents
as well as a very recent
client success story
with our partners from Genspark,
where they use RFT to move
from one of the cloud models
to an open-source Fireworks model.
And they had around like a 20% increase
in quality while reducing
latency and costs.
So what we do essentially is we wanna make
it really simple for companies
to use their expertise
through this data flywheel
so that they can fine-tune really quickly,
deploy really quickly,
and whenever there's a new model drop,
they can just switch the new model,
fine-tune it again and
deploy again, right?
As well for everybody
that took their ML 101,
there's covariate drift and data drift
and things change, right?
So we make it really fast for companies
just iterate through the data flywheel.
We have a couple of examples here, right?
VLM fine-tuning
and how we use an open-source model,
a Qwen model, fine tune it
on the specific data set.
And you see that we don't only
match the closed-source provider,
but we beat it, right?
And then the same with RFT,
with reinforcer link fine-tuning.
This is for a text to SQL use case.
Same, right?
We not only match,
but we beat the closed-source provider.
So again, really it's
all about owning your AI.
The model is your product.
The model is your a IP
and a company's real
moat is in their own data
and in their own expertise
and how they put that
into their AI models for
their specific use cases.
Now, why am I talking about this
on AWS re:Invent?
Well, because we built our entire stack
on top of AWS re:Invent,
or sorry, on top of AWS,
not on top of AWS re:Invent.
So essentially we use EC2, ECS and EKS
and we're just an inference
and optimization layer that runs right
on top of it, right?
So the FireOptimizer,
the fine-tuning that I described,
as well as the incredibly
fast inference engine,
is just this software layer
that runs on top of AWS.
Now we work with companies
from gen AI startups
that move incredibly fast
and they use our SaaS platform all the way
to legacy companies that have
to be incredibly compliant,
incredibly secure
in terms of data privacy.
And that's why we've developed
these different deployment options
on top of AWS, right?
So from our SaaS platform
where quote unquote,
"it's the least private,"
even though we do have
zero data retention,
et cetera, but it's all
in our environment, right,
and then all the way to fully air gapped.
So if you want to deploy Fireworks
in a fully air gapped environment,
meaning absolutely
nothing leaves your VPC,
then we can do that through deploying
through a Kubernetes cluster
or as well as SageMaker.
And then everything in between, right?
So we can deploy with AWS private link
where the network is secure
or as well through non-air gapped BYOC,
where we basically just have
what we call a control plane, right?
Okay.
Now I'm gonna talk in
the last five minutes
that I have about some
client success stories
so that you guys kind of believe me
in all the BS that I'm saying now.
One example, and of course I'm gonna start
with one that I can't use the logo,
but a very large grocery
delivery platform,
they basically use us to
fine-tune a very small
Llama 10B 8B model
in a search use case, right?
So these are the types of use cases
that are requiring incredibly low latency.
They're handling around two to 3 million
daily queries of
what they call ambiguous queries, right?
So let's say that you're using Uber Eats
or Instacart or DoorDash
or whatever it is,
like sometimes users will put something
that is very vague, right,
and you want to make it so
that an LLM, a very fast LLM
can do things like query expansion,
it'll rewrite it, maybe
it'll tag it, et cetera.
They use Fireworks to
fine tune that model,
reduce the search the
search support tickets
by 50% and run everything
at 300 milliseconds or less.
And that's not only technical targets,
but also they actually ran an A and B test
and they saw that they increased uplift
once they moved to Fireworks.
Another example is Notion.
They're a great great partner of us.
If you guys are a Notion user,
I'm a huge Notion user.
A lot of Notion...
Yeah, good stuff, okay?
If you love Notion AI,
then you'll love Fireworks AI.
A lot of Notion AI runs on Fireworks AI.
They've also made use of fine-tuning
and very small models
for very fast inference.
So they actually moved
from a closed-source provider to us.
They saw around a 4x lower latency
to 500 milliseconds and below,
and they've scaled
to a hundred million users plus, right?
So again, incredibly low latency
at scale while increasing quality
through fine-tuning.
And then the last one I'll talk
about is DoorDash, right?
So I talked a little bit about VLMs,
vision language models.
We don't only have text
models, we also have VLMs
and we have a lot of,
I'd say it's a growing
field, a lot of interest
from clients in these use cases.
One very interesting one
is this product catalog cleansing, right?
So these companies have millions
and millions of images.
They want to basically label them,
as I said, right,
Jeans, shorts, pants,
et cetera, automatically
and to a high degree of
fidelity and accuracy.
What they've done is,
for example, DoorDash,
they fine-tune an open-source model
that is running 3x faster
than the closed-source model
that they were using before,
while increasing quality with fine-tuning
and reducing the cost by 10%.
So all in all right,
we provide basically a one stop shop
for anything that you need to build.
We call magical AI
applications to really match
and beat closed-source provider quality
while keeping latency incredibly low
and costs very controlled.
Thank you very much.
If you have any questions,
we're somewhere around there.
Don't tell me
what the number of our area is
because I have terrible working memory,
but you will find us
somewhere around there
and if not, I'll walk around here
and I can tell you.
Yeah, happy to answer any questions
and hopefully I'll meet the 10 people
that listened to me
and hopefully I wasn't super boring.
So anyways, thank you so much.